Here is the project you're going
to help complete and get working.
It's a little quiz app that reads
a phrase to you in a random language and
displays three choices.
One of these is the correct one.
You can make a choice or
hear another phrase.
The app you know if what you
choose is correct or not.
We built this app with two purposes.
First, we think can be a fun little
app to show your family and friends.
Here and your hands after
a few minutes on the Udacity
iOS developer nanodegree you have an app
that can speak in multiple languages.
The second purpose is in my
mind the most important one.
With this app you can get
a glimpse of the power of iOS.
We did not use pre recorded audio iOS is
speaking in these different languages
on the fly.
Let me stress that point again iOS is
able to speak any text that you have
in a variety of languages with
just a few lines of code.
Okay let's get you
started in the structure
notes you will find to start a project.
Wrap this project and open it in
Xcode I'll guide you from there.
We will cover Xcode in depth
in the next lesson, but
if you want an overview now, feel
free to go through our Xcode tutorial
in beginning oiOS by
following the link provided.